ils ont sauté le pas ce dimanche matin
pas de repos dominical pour ces amateurs
de sport au contraire un programme
chargé
échauffement des muscs renforcement
musculaire raffinement de la taille et
beaucoup de cardio
ici on est là pour dépenser de l'énergie
et avoir un coeur plus en forme
[Musique]
et
après deux heures de fitness de musique
et de bonne humeur
à l'arrivée c'est génial franchement un
plaisir
mais ces bons résultats permettent eux
défouler après une semaine très chargée
au travail ils viennent de tous les
coins de l'île pour assister à ce cours
particuliers et la lieu une fois par
mois
allier danse et musique pour rendre les
cours plus ludique ce concept attire de
nombreuses générations vraiment un
succès réunir entre 3 200 et 300
personnes une fois par mois sur cette
magnifique place est vraiment un succès
pour nous que nous avons un public
intergénérationnel c'était le but
important de pouvoir rappeler pendant le
cours que cas les options qui existent
aussi pour permettre aux gens qu'ils ont
par exemple quand des traumatismes que
je nous autres qui a des mouvements pour
eux donc je le répète sans cesse pendant
le cours et puis ceux qui veulent plus
de challenge que nous fait le plus de 2
on va dire de aller un peu plus loin
dans l'effort mais je leur propose ainsi
des le monde ment beaucoup plus intense
même si la coach l'on confie que le
sport c'est tous les jours pour d'autres
faire une activité physique permet de se
préserver à l'approché des fêtes
[Musique]
on élimine avant de commencer à
reprendre au quai s'est donné à fond
aujourd'hui marche aussi qu'un dunkerque
d'ici quelques semaines
à tout prendre on va réfléchir la mort
ont fait qu'avant ça se passe pratiquer
une activité est important pour la santé
et de bien-être
mais cette fois la reprise du sport
devoir attendre à la deuxième semaine de
janvier mère noël et ses lutins semble
déjà bien encore pour affronter cette
fête de noël
[Musique]